As you've probably figured out by now, Bootstrap has a lot of
really great functionality that's going to save you a lot of time.
But you probably want your site to be a little bit more unique and have some
styles that are really specific to it that you can't find within Bootstrap.
To include your own custom styles, you're going to need another stylesheet that
has everything you want to achieve that's not included in Bootstrap.
To do so, add a new file to the css directory or
the css folder called style.css.
Inside style.css, we'll include the styles that are unique to our page.
Remember, you're going to want to start working with the largest elements and
then move to smaller and more specific elements inside style.css.
Where should you start?
Would you start with the background color, the margins or padding of the page,
or the font styles, including the color, typeface, and weight?